the Joe Rogan experience that's me like
if someone if someone I love talking
trash right that's my thing and in
strongman it's not very popular like
when I got it oh no they don't
it's very old-school like you're
supposed to do your work not act like
you're supposed to get paid not act like
you're supposed to want any attention
not draw any attention towards yourself
really it's like it's like karate in
like 1960 you know be respectful of the
way and I totally get that I understand
that and it I mean I don't think anyone
can get to the top echelon without
having that respect but it's it's
ridiculous for people who've never been
at that on that on that level to tell
other people how they're supposed to
behave right if I want to talk [ __ ] I'm
gonna talk [ __ ] I thought I was talking
[ __ ] to you or just out of class that's
just what we do yeah it's fun
stalking is fun and also it's like I
feel like that makes it more
entertaining and we want more eyes on
the sport exactly I mean that's what my
argument about the UFC I always like it
when people talk some [ __ ] right and and
win or lose sometimes you have to eat
that like what the kid that Ben Askren
exactly a flat line doodle but I mean he
also took that on the chin he put up a
post like right after they're like well
that's suck yeah he takes him better
than anybody he's got a great
personality
yeah massive it all said is not even
over listen he goes I don't like that
dude he goes if I see him at Whole Foods
he's getting smacked down oh [ __ ]
imagine the guy flatlines you with the
[ __ ] fastest-ever kayo in UFC history
and he's promising you that if you're
looking for Brussels sprouts a smack in
the face yeah he already gave him two
extra shots to the face which by the way
people are giving him [ __ ] for its
that's his job
yes it's go to the referee stops you
well especially when there's a heated
contest like that way you talk so much
[ __ ] and he insulted Maz vidal's manhood
he talked about this in the ethnicity
talk we said a lot of [ __ ] that really
pissed mom's butt all off right and he's
like why and he had a statement of I was
like why is it okay to talk all this
[ __ ] online about me before the fight
but then after I knocked him out I'm not
supposed to showboat I'm not supposed to
celebrate right the [ __ ] out another
if you got a problem with it stop them
winners get to do what they want he's
ice cold man when he said and it's not
over if I see so intense savage savage
that I lose though it was so brilliant
because Askren always grabs your legs
and if you get that close to him he's
gonna think like almost like he has to
grab you right
it's his instinct and you saw him like I
saw somebody put a video up in practice
and he he would be rounded or like out
to the outside and then acted as if it
was gonna be just a normal step and then
it's two quick steps of me oh and you
see how stiff he was before he hit I'm
sure you saw but damn he was stiff yeah
what his head was up and one leg was up
I mean he was staff though that was a
rut here at here he is practicing yeah
that was an absolutely ruthless ko and
it's the fastest ever UFC kale at five
seconds but really he was out cold at
two
oh yeah yeah yeah I mean he just took
the rest a few seconds to get there yeah
whatever maybe three I guess maybe I
mean whatever it took for him to run
over there it seems like two seconds
who's like one one-thousand two it's
over oh yeah [ __ ] at least he got a lot
of face time before you got in the ring
yeah
[Applause]